[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: This
Quick Start shows you
how to perform basic operations
in Datastore using the Google
Cloud Platform Console.
Go to the Datastore Entities
page in the Google Cloud
Platform Console.
This page allows you to store,
query, update, and delete data.
Click Create Entity.
On the Create Entity page, use
Default for Namespace and Task
for Kind.
Under Properties, use
the Add Property button
to add the following
properties--
a description of type String
whose value is Learn Google
Cloud Datastore.
Click Done to set the property.
Use the Add Property button to
add a second property, named
Created, with the Type Date and
Time, with the current time.
Click Done to set
this [? property. ?]
Now let's add a third property,
called Done, of type Boolean,
with a value of False.
Click Done to set the
property, and click Create.
And note that the console
now displays the task entity
that you just created.
You just stored data
in Cloud Datastore.
Now that our Datastore is up
and running, let's run a query
and click on Query by GQL.
Enter "Select, star,
from task" as the query.
Note that "task"
is case-sensitive.
When we click Run
Query, we can see
that the results show the
task entity we just created.
You can add a query filter
to restrict the results
to entities that meet
specific criteria.
Let's run a query
such as "Select, star,
from task where done equals
false," and click Run Query.
Note that "done"
is case-sensitive.
And the results show the task
entity that you just created,
since its done value is false.
Congratulations.
You've just stored and queried
data in Cloud Datastore.
[MUSIC PLAYING]